from 2014 I started gambling thousands
and thousands and thousands but then I'd
go home and be so miserable and so
depressed and so guilty
Despair and shame but still he couldn't
stop
Lewis who didn't want us to share his
real name has lost thousands of pounds
to a gambling addiction
it started with small bets on football
matches but soon escalated I could have
my own house with all the money I've
lost I could have an easy life
I've been working and money doesn't stay
in the account for more than two days
he tried to stop in 2019 by signing up
to gamstop a self-exclusion tool backed
by gambling companies when customers
sign up they should be blocked from
spending any more money except it
doesn't always work
a change of address was all it took for
Lewis to slip through the system he was
able to reopen a dormant account with
William Hill last year and lost
thousands of pounds
in a few days they act like they're
protecting you with these self-exclusion
zones in place yet you're not protected
you're not it's so dangerous
William Hill maintains that it did
nothing wrong but campaigners have long
been skeptical of the industry's efforts
to self-regulate when it is sober Todds
with its primary motive to make money
now the government is taking a tougher
stance a long-awaited white paper will
outline new rules that have not been
updated for more than a decade
I'm hoping the white paper deals with
our requests which are to bring what is
probably the most unregulated gambling
industry in the developed world into a
more regulated sense this needs to be
brought under control so that it is not
abusive any longer for those affected by
gambling the changes could not come soon
enough
in the era of the smartphone the
industry has changed enormously but the
laws are still lagging behind when it
became a real issue was when I got my
first phone and I was able to go online
and start online gambling all the
operators need to have some sort of
consistent approach to people who maybe
have a problem there's so much
red flags you can see on hours and 16
different accounts probably spending
when I shouldn't have done and those
flags will have been everywhere for some
it's come far too late but campaigners
are hoping that the new rules will
finally put people before profit gabri
now on Sky News